warning this episode may contain content
that is not suitable for children viewer
discretion is
advised so the other way those Spirits
they won my trust my full trust is what
it looked like my dead mother and she
talks like her she acts like her and my
mother came down in a spaceship she
knows my soul so when I asked her about
who I am she said of course she's around
me way things are everywhere she
protects me every day every
day welcome everybody we have Chris
laying in the house today and this is
actually our second time starting here
because we've had some issues already
showing up lights blinking that are
plugged in that act like they don't work
we get started the stuff goes off I'm
excited about what you're going to bring
today because Chris has made three films
this is the third in a Trilogy of of
films that really are discussing
spiritual warfare in our modern day and
age here Charmed by Darkness awesome
film uh the um beware of angels that
really was an eyeopener just to like you
know be careful what you ask for and
mystified is going to bring it all full
circle and explain what's happening
today I'm excited to have you on Chris
thank you Scotty and really appreciate
the opportunity to be here on little
light with such a great calling you have
for um for this time in history amen
awesome we we got a little taste of the
Warfare behind the scenes that we can't
see before we even got started with this
interview today um but thankfully this
is being recorded so that people can be
aware that we're going to be premiering
this film on October
29 Sunday awesome the thing the devil
hates the most is shining light on a
dark subject and that is effectively
what you're doing here is you're
bringing some light to a subject that is
really has its fingers in a lot of
different things right
now yeah you know The ecumenical
movement right the movement to join
hands with with all the religions coming
together to make what what many of many
of your viewers know about what is is
being discussed as a one world religion
what is that this film doesn't really
use those terms but it uses stories and
it uses um celebrities it uses clips
from films it uses a lot of different
ways to
illustrate um how this original lie has
been presented increasingly so as an
answer to Humanity's
problems meditation is being promoted
it's called mindfulness you guys talk
about these things to warn people out
there that these Altered States Of
Consciousness that they try to make
copacetic by saying oh it's just a
breathing exercise you're just clearing
your mind of getting all that stuff out
and renewing your Consciousness it's
like a
reset but in fact what's happening today
is in in several US states and in the
country of Australia they're legalizing
psychedelic drugs and so everything
that's been promoted for the last 30
years for mindfulness which is derived
from Zen Buddhism and um I have a clip
to share today from World War II that
actually shows how Japanese soldiers
were were using Zen Buddhist ideas and
practices to attain Enlightenment so
that they achieve a no self where they
don't exist and neither does the enemy
so nobody gets killed mhm wow yeah it
doesn't matter I mean can you imagine
that mind game that they're playing with
people like here fly your plane into you
know this it'll be you know the end of
you as you know it but there is no you
so I mean it's really just a a crazy
thing that that we have tricked people
into believing well people may hear
these terminologies like psychedelics
mysticism and all of that and think
that's so far removed from their faith
whether it's Christian or what have you
like that those elements are not in my
belief system um but what the film is
great in doing is very thorough in
defining what mysticism is also showing
the goal of it and and showing how it's
actually seeping into all the different
religions and how the goal is to bring
all the religions together and from what
I got from it it's because language is
changing M
or they would use a word that's familiar
with a a people in this religion but
they change the the meaning or they
change the the original intent and then
all of a sudden you're wrapped into the
things that you thought was so far
removed it's very interesting and then
of course wrapping it up with what does
the Bible say you know what what does
God truly call us to do and by observing
the truth you're able to see the
deception yeah candy that's beautiful a
beautiful summary of the film I think
we're finished
now let's take a look at a clip it's a
portion of the opening sequence to help
people get a big picture idea of the
issues that you've so wonderfully just
summarized Mystics claim that all wisdom
comes from inside you that you're
already God a so-called spark of
divinity an immortal soul that Altered
States Of Consciousness reveal true
reality that everything is one and all
religions lead to the same place God is
manifesting himself in all the religions
in some way and in different ways yes
and so we can
transcend the intensity of the different
interpretations by the experience of the
Oneness that comes through contemplative
prayer today many universities offer
courses in the christianized form of
mysticism called spiritual
formation businesses and schools sponsor
mindfulness
meditation several US states and
Australia recently legalized various
types of psychedelic drugs while the US
government is funding its
research science and religion are
merging Reviving The Ancient Pagan
belief system called
Shamanism the iasa is usually described
as a grandmother spirit and I met
her you know our ancestors out there
right and if you're open we could use
that Christ is not an individual Christ
is a collective is man really Immortal
was Jesus just a
man if everyone experiences their own
inner truth then who makes the
rules there's nothing to believe you
just go and you know it to be true for
yourself where did mysticism come from
and where is it taking
usog Saints of all religions Saints of
all religions we bow to you
allow wow that's awesome man that's
intense yeah it was really well done it
it is interesting to me that like you
know if if they say there's parts and
bits of every religion and they're all
kind of you know like basically tying
you back to the same then there would be
many ways and paths to God that's right
where the Bible is giving us a clear
line of what is acceptable and what is
not for this day and age and I love how
you can actually take a step back and
observe these kind of things but then
you can go to the Bible and you have
clear-cut evidence that says Jesus is
the way the truth and the life you know
no one will come to the father but by me
and and that just does away with all
this deception you know but that's what
the deception is oh he didn't really
mean it that way like this is actually
what he meant even though the words are
seemingly clear right that's exactly
right he's the way not a way and that
guy said Jesus isn't like a person it's
a collective which made me think of
First John 4:3 and every spirit that
confesses not that Jesus Christ has come
in the flesh is not of God and this is
the spirit of antichrist where of ye
have heard that it should come and even
now already is in the world so anyone
who's saying Jesus Christ is not flesh
but he's a collective already is the
spirit of antichrist predicted in the
Bible 2,000 years ago we're living it
yeah and we live in a day and age where
you can actually quickly search that and
Bam come up with the information we live
in an Information Age there's no excuse
when Christ returns there's not going to
be an excuse man back in the day used to
cost $11,000 for a book mhm or and then
then we got to an age where you could go
to the library and check out things but
now it's like we have the entire world
library at our fingertips there are um
there's a lot of history presented in
mystified and um and as well as
celebrities like Elvis Presley who um
kind of validate what we see in history
as coming like a Mac Truck on on culture
today but the 60s were really kind of
like the The Fountain Head of the big
push uh you'll see how in the
1960s uh Elvis Presley and the Beatles
and psychedelic drugs and Vatican 2
which was the huge Fountain Head of what
we're seeing today in in the world in
culture um because every one of them all
end up saying the same thing about Jesus
Christ and about the nature of man
and that's why in the subtitle I was
convicted that we needed to say
something about the
Antichrist yeah because so many people
in this peacey culture we're in are no
longer feeling free to say that there is
an absolute truth yeah because that's
another thing that we bring up and we
show the parallel between what a heretic
was called in the Dark Ages who were
burned for being Heretics just for
believing that the Bible should be read
by the common person that the priest
doesn't have the answers that you go
directly to God for confession for for
forgiveness for your sins through Jesus
Christ and the scriptures were that
Bastion of truth that filter through
which everything we experience is
filtered and without the Bible the devil
knows that he can play both sides and
get away with it and that's what we're
seeing today yeah and without the Bible
there's just like false sense of
security because for those who have
studied this out they know that the
Antichrist is both a political and a
religious system and if this is news to
you you should watch mystified for more
detailed U but from the verse Mikey just
said there's a spirit of an antichrist
which means just because you may not be
part of that political system or
religious system anyone could have the
spirit of the Antichrist and you could
be so easily lulled and persuaded to
join that and so it's all around we we
need to be on guard and not just think
because we're not involved in this
particular thing that we're we're fine
yes that's a good point Kendy I I
believe that
um it's amazing how the Lord leads um I
wasn't intending for certain of these um
metaphors to be included it wasn't in my
plan and my outline but God led me to
Genesis 28 and showed me the relevance
of Jacob's Ladder and one of the
shocking revelations the Holy Spirit
showed me
is his grandfather Abraham had been
called out of
where he was called out of her which is
was part of Mesopotamia or Babylon
ancient Babylon so Abraham was a
Babylonian Abraham knew everything about
this ancient zigurat that the temple
priests would climb in
trance and through that altered state of
consciousness this was a metaphor for
ascending kind of like the ch in
Hinduism when you when yoga when you go
into this this Kundalini this releasing
the serpent seven chakras the same thing
with the they get that from
Mesopotamia because the zigurat had
seven
stages and the chakra interestingly has
seven levels to the infinite the very
top is is connecting with your with your
higher self with the Atman as the Hindus
believe but it's really all the same
it's it's like Kendy was saying earlier
they just had different terminology that
they use so God gave me Jacob's Ladder
which represents Jesus
Christ and the historical connection to
the ziggurats which was essentially a
humanistic way of attaining eternal life
or
immortality this is what they believed
that in an altered state you would
actually communicate with the Gods in
the afterlife M so they would deify dead
people MH and that's what happened in
World War II in
Shintoism which is an ancient which
arose out of shamanism the Shinto
priests in Japan would actually convert
these these dead War um Japanese uh
soldiers into Gods interesting it really
is just a different terminology because
there's the Christ Consciousness kind of
like in the New Age movement you got ego
death with like the the cenogenics
um and then you have Nirvana all these
things it's just like whatever you're
into you can reach this state of
Enlightenment and it's just a different
way some is going to take meditation and
some is going to take you know take this
aciid or iasa or whatever but yeah
there's different ways to reach the same
thing so there's one way to Christ one
way to God is Christ and then there
Satan has all these other avenues the
broad way to destruction but I have a
question about that CU in the film you
do make mention that the state itself or
being in that state isn't you can't say
whether it's good or bad because God did
that with multiple people in the Bible
so would you say the difference is how
one gets there would you say that um God
is the one who initiates the good type
of altered state versus if we're the
ones always trying to get there whether
it's through psychedelics or what have
you that's what opens the door to being
in a bad State how how do you see the
difference yeah this is another thing
the Lord showed me through prayer and
and actually memorizing whole chapters
in the book of Acts where this is
brought up this is very clear in the
book of Acts the Trans State the Greek
word is ecstasy that's where we get the
word ecstasy from which means out of
your mind or out of
body so yes these people in every case
that you see in the book of Acts they're
praying actively praying and we go in
the film and we show the biblical basis
for prayer how Jesus prayed how Moses
prayed he talked to God as a friend it
was a very conscious kind of a thing in
prayer and so once once and we also make
the statement that everything you see in
the New Testament with Jesus and the
apostles had to agree with their Bible
which we call the Old Testament right
right and this is very comforting to me
as a Christian to see all of how this
fits because there are things Paul says
he says I went to the third heaven I
don't know how I got there in the body
or out of the body I don't know in the
body or out of the body he doesn't know
and and the mystics Christian so-called
Mystics point to that and say see he was
he was an amazing Mystic he was
meditating yeah he was he was having a
trip out of body experience and so he
had to be a Mystic because he said that
but once you understand the nature of
man as it's taught in the Jewish holy
scriptures the Old Testament then you
know that whatever was said in the New
Testament had to agree with with that
the Holy Spirit doesn't contradict
himself amen so getting back to your
question based on their Bible theirs
their prayers were very conscious and
very active and they talked to God as a
friend and so when you see in the book
of Acts Peter and Paul both and you see
it in the film both confessing that they
were in a trance but they're first
saying I was praying and then I fell
into a trance you see it in the Old
Testament with balum M also fell into a
trans but these are all active frontal
lobe kinds of activities and
surrendering to the Holy Spirit through
Jesus Christ gives him permission to
take over our faculties if there's a
special message that he believes needs
to be given through an altered state
which in and of itself is not good or
evil and this is in the Bible and so I
thank God that He gave me a way to
understand it so I could share this with
people MH because honestly until this
year I I thought that that a trans state
was inherently evil
right but then I was like well the
devil's going to have a a hey day if we
don't have an answer for this it's
almost like the god designed the
hardware to have a communication device
and that communication device is just
getting like robbed you know it's like
it's meant for you to communicate with
God that's where we actually talk to God
it's in the front L when you do drugs
you drink alcohol you go into a state of
hypnosis or any of those those are the
things that affect the frontal lob right
which effectively he's hijacking that
system and then communicating his
message to you but I I see a stark
difference between those individuals in
the Bible they're usually interacting
with God and it's like they're focused
about other people whereas all these
other religions are all about you and
it's you you you you're focused on
yourself getting more knowledge or
higher up or whatever like that and and
and who gets the glory do you have to go
to a shaman do you have to take the drug
the mushroom like who where are you
getting the access to this uh trans
versus in the Bible they always give
glory to God praying and you're always
going to God sorry candy that's right
one of the things you'll notice in the
film is very much like this you will see
the pattern very intentional pattern the
people who are doing and we're going to
show a clip of of of the one of the main
features of a guy that was his name is
Samuel who was delivered
from um psychedelic drugs and the Occult
as a connected with this but you'll see
in the film a constant reference to
surrendering
surrendering um these celebrities are
all saying it and they're also saying I
came with an intention mhm so first they
come and they tell the shaman their
intention at the ceremony before they
take this DNT this active agent in iow
or maybe it's the toad or maybe it's
some African root that you'll see in the
film from Africa all containing
something that takes you with fire into
an En an enhanced altered state beyond
what you would experience in
meditation but but the point is is the
spirits have no permission to take over
your faculties as a human being Jesus
Christ when he died gave Humanity the
right to choose who they would serve
amen There are rules that we can't see
MH behind the scenes like what we saw
before we started filming today all
kinds of unseen things happen happening
that don't usually happen in this room
MH and those Spirits know that they have
to be given permission to take over
someone's faculties and so you'll see
that reference constantly first they
come with an intention this is what I
would like to have done for me by the
spirit Realm
I want a wife I want a new job I want uh
to to have success in social
media uh but you'll see in the film one
person came and she's one of the feature
stories she asked for the
truth and the the whole film is
basically launched in this beautiful
story of of that there is a truth there
is a person m and the truth should lead
us to that person amen it also gives
insight into the Rules of Engagement of
the spiritual realm because seemingly
the person whose story is is shown in
this film she made the choice for the
darkness but then God reaches in through
the darkness because of what she asked
for which is the truth and that is what
gave him entrance into her heart it
reminded me of the demoniac in the Bible
I mean he was out of his mind and like
demons were manifesting out of his Jesus
heard his heart cry he wanted to be
saved he wanted the truth so it's like
that's why Christian Christians who have
loved ones or people they know that it
seems like they're so far out prayer is
so important it's so powerful cuz you
don't know what that person is saying in
their heart and how God could reach them
even in the darkest of pits amen yeah
so so what we're we have a very simple
message in this film and that is there
is only one truth there is only one way
if you want to have have peace in this
life if you want to have joy in this
life if you want to have hope for an
afterlife there's one way to get there
MH and it takes 3 hours by the way this
film is 3 hours long and it has to be I
if you would have told me I would do if
you would have told me that I would do a
three-hour long documentary I would have
laughed at
you but God apparently had other plans
because there's stuff about Buddhism in
here there's stuff about Hinduism you
saw those uh Hindu looking people U
praying and bowing to the Saints in the
clip I showed you earlier Elvis Presley
according to several biographies tried
to join that group and it was a very
famous and many of your viewers will
know about pandza Yogananda who was a
famous Hindu Guru who came into the
United States to supposedly preach
Christianity and Hindu well they just
put Jesus in the line with all of the
other Hindu gurus from from the past and
then they threw in the Saints of all
religions and they said that this was
kind of the essence of Christianity
because Jesus was included there new age
does the same thing with the ascended
masters exactly the that's all they did
Yogananda was a genius in his age but
then New Age kind of kind of became a
culmination of all of these voices in
the early 20th century but um which is
really a slam on Jesus to say he's just
one of many as opposed to he is is the I
mean the whole Bible centers around this
character the whole war in heaven
started over this character you know
it's like this is this is a very very
very important person in the context of
the great controversy and you can see
how they're just digging at him by like
a he's just one of the he's one of the
other on they say you shouldn't say that
that that's not what the bible really
means and you're deluded if you think
that he's the son of God and all these
things that's the key the key is that by
experience these things like Elvis was
Elvis started meditating every day twice
a day
and eventually his brain wir by the he
grew up in a Protestant Christian he
started thinking that he was Jesus right
he did for a time he did for a time he
did or people were claiming he did okay
I think that's where all this stuff
leads right the most important yeah the
most important person I mean he grew up
in a Christian environment I'm sure he
knows who Jesus is and then you just
bend in your mind to like oh I'm this
important person and but he did he did
famously for the viewers that know this
fact because I was very careful in
making statements about Elvis because
there's probably been no one more
studied in the modern age as far as
celebrity in fact it's been said that he
was taken more photographs were taken of
him than anyone in history wow um and
and and and he was quoted in a concert
someone said he basically worshiping him
as Christ and he said there's only one
Jesus and I'm not him I actually
remember seeing
that but but here's the point you can
you can you can be part of this wide
Road message and give Jesus respect yeah
but you can be terribly deceived because
he's not the Christ that was predicted
in the Old Testament hundreds of years
before Jesus came so Christ according to
what is being preached and this was his
favorite book this was Elvis's Bible it
became his Bible and it was written in
1914 by a Lutheran who literally
channeled it it's interesting the the
the the parallels that you see of all of
these famous that become famous some
celebrity makes a book famous it's not
known by many people until Elvis picks
it up like the secret Oprah Steve Harvey
and all these people Elvis kind of did
that to this book The I believe that's
why the devil he these are his kingpins
if he can work through those people he
realizes their influence is what's going
to push this thing forward wow yeah and
so this be and so Elvis was giving these
out by the hundreds in fact graceand
this book on the right with his picture
on it was actually
republished by graceand after he died
and um so it's this book but with a new
cover with it wow yeah but see this is
this is this is what I'm saying it's
like there's there's really two ways to
look at this if those who find their own
life right will lose it in the end those
who lose their life now will find it in
the end you can see that in all of these
disciplines the ones that push you back
to Center on yourself as opposed to you
know someone else I think that's just
like I am you you know you got to wonder
how some how how this happens how does a
Christian slip into into this and so is
it fair to say that he was looking for a
feeling he was looking for an experience
let's say that his motive from what I've
seen in my research was the same as
Roger Mor knows Elvis grew up being
taught a doctrine of Hell Fire eternal
hell fire and Roger morau decided God
was a tyrant because he burns people
supposedly forever and ever and ever and
never ending punishment and Elvis saw
that Doctrine also as as as as something
that separated him from his Christian
faith and so he was looking for
something where he could find a god of
love and and when you have that giant v
Vortex of need once religion fails you
people will reach out and seek all kinds
of things and instead of going to the
source to figure out is it true cuz it's
not it's interesting how lies is what
brings people out of the church but when
you see like the pastor believes it
these priests believe it the majority of
Christians believe it I know but that's
you think well they're the ones that
read the thing all the time also it's
the experiential part of what they
experience in an altered state in fact
you'll hear some of the leading Roman
Catholic monks and authors in the film
admitting that the whole the whole
teaching of contemplation which is the
christianized word for Altered States Of
Consciousness that they teach
contemplation to unlearn everything
you've been taught before they're
actually admitting that and so what
happens to a Christian when they start
practicing what they think is just
relaxation techniques
is a reprogramming of your mind about
what true reality is including what
you're reading in the Bible mhh yeah
what does the word contemplate mean yeah
that's a misnomer there's nothing
contemplative about it doesn't mean to
think so the devil it's it's to meditate
to look thoughtfully for a long time at
something or or to think about but in
contemplative prayer or contemplative
prayer right you're clearing your mind
you're not thinking exactly right and
they admit one of the most famous
Catholic monks in in history of the
Modern Age post Vatican 2 voices he
actually says God and our true self are
not separate though we are not God God
and our true self are the same thing oh
so you see the sounds like uh what the
serpent was saying in the garden you see
this just terminology anything that's
going to try to make you bigger than you
yeah should be which is nothing by the
way true self is a code word true self
is the christianized or C or the the
word or the term that the Roman Catholic
monks the mon the monastics is a word
you'll hear in the film a lot these are
the nuns and monks from centuries who
came forward and that's what Vatican 2
did it launched what they experienc in
mysticism so-called
Christian um truths true self is the
same term as in Hinduism Atman or the
higher yourself in New Age it's the same
thing it's the IM it's the immortal part
the spark of divinity that doesn't die
and it is there that God wants to talk
to you and so they're teaching that you
don't go outside to communicate with God
because he's already inside you you just
need to activate be awaken to it wow so
subtle because he does live inside Satan
so subtle man yeah this is the Christian
this is what Stephanie fell into but
Stephanie was shielded from a lot of
this deception she did have an addiction
to contemplative prayer and you'll see
her journey but the thing is most people
when they Christians and getting back to
kend's question about Elvis and other
Christians falling for this the more
they practice
this non conceptual prayer it's called
contemplative prayer which is a misnomer
be careful cuz it Doesn't mean what they
say right the more they practice it the
less they do mental prayer which is the
prayer that the Bible teaches us to pray
to the God in heaven who then becomes
the one inside you who's always there so
they to a person they almost all give up
reading the Bible yeah and praying
mental prayers and this is what
dominates this becomes so
addictive and I have quotes from Jesuits
who actually admit this and they're not
in the film there was too much to put in
the film but I'm sure we'll have movie
extras but there's there's an admission
that this is so powerful it will
dominate your life see if you just read
in the beginning of Revelation where it
says Jesus is knocking on the door of
your heart that's an active invitation
you need to be giving to him access to
your heart he's not already he's not
he's not going to be in you without you
inviting him you know what I mean he's
respectful like that I've I've talked to
personal friends and family members when
I'm really trying to show them like this
is what the Bible says about whatever
topic we're talking about like here's
the scripture here's the scripture
here's the scripture I've heard from
more than one of them say look man we
have the Holy Spirit now like we don't
even need the Bible because the holy
spirit gives us truth and I'm like who
like it just blows my mind and they'll
say stuff like well what do you think
about when you drive by that person
walking down the road and and you can't
get out of your mind I need to pick them
up that's happened to me before I was
saying see that's the Holy Spirit
guiding I do believe that but it's still
God's word and and what it says is truth
and you have if it says it over and over
and over it has to be truth it doesn't
matter what you feel or believe your
your feelings don't matter it's a light
into your path yeah right and a lamp
into your feet like the Bible has the it
has to give us our Direction you're
stumbling around in the dark yeah that's
true it's like what's the purpose of
Christ being within you or the holy
spirit being within you it's for you to
be a servant not for you to be self-
glorified but also think about it how
loving would God be if he did not
provide an objective word a written word
for mankind throughout history knowing
himself better than we do that there are
fallen angels that come in sheep's
clothing they come professing to be
God's angels giving you truth being
benefactors of
mankind if you in fact believe in the
Bible that's fine they don't
care I I I think films like what you've
just created here is so vitally
important because you know if you grow
up in the Christian faith and you don't
really look into all this stuff you
don't really understand what these terms
mean or there's no context to you that
it's easy to slide air in there because
you really don't have a context of that
to me it's so beneficial when you watch
something like this and you go oh this
and this and this is is where this leads
and so when I hear those terms pop up in
Christian circles it's like no no no no
I know where that comes from that comes
from these Mystics over here I promised
that we would get to the Psychedelic
drugs and I wanted to present Samuel and
Vala's story briefly and there's a clip
of his actual experience he took some
video that's never been seen publicly
before when he was in the new age and
practicing his own meditation and taking
magic mushrooms and going and doing iasa
he was getting power from these Fallen
Angels but he didn't know yeah he
thought they were just Spirits out there
floating around and and they knew his
mother who had died and he was seeing
his mother when he went for these iasa
ceremonies as well and you'll see a clip
of it but but you'll see how this is
coming like a freight train on Humanity
right now and um
and it's because the Demonic realm is
you you can see you can see the pressure
on the minds of men the fear that and
the anger and the violence and the
suicide rates they're all climbing and
and people are grasping for answers and
solutions and supposedly this plant
medicine so they call it is now being
validated and even Christians are
starting to do it I'm seeing churches
pop up 501 c3s that are doing iasa
Retreats oh my that's insane and um but
you have to do something with Jesus in
the nature of man in order
to engage in those shamanistic practices
because that's where that's the Fountain
Head that's where meditation Altered
States out of- body experiences all of
these different things come from ancient
Shamanism including psychedelic drugs
and so I wanted to show how this is
increasingly being being christianized
um surprisingly you know what's crazy is
that uh a lot of the times it's
Christianity or Christian values that's
to blame for this um suicide levels
going up and all that kind of stuff
because what they're saying you know
you're you're you're your biology at
Birth you're not something else or what
have you and these are targeted as
Christian values and they're saying well
that's why people are miserable that's
why people are committing suicides
because if you're pushing your belief
down our throats and it's like what I'm
glad you brought that up because there
if you listen long enough they all say
there's no Dogma there's no Doctrine you
just experience it and that's how you
know it's
true without Doctrine we don't know how
to live and what we're seeing is is the
increase increasing out result of of a
world without an anchor yeahh you know
so this is samel andalo and I promised
you we would I promised the viewers last
time we would get here are they um
related in any way or a couple or they
are uncle and niece okay yep and um his
older siblings were so much older than
him when they grew up in Iraq that's
where they're from they grew up in a
Muslim family and um that's why this
story is such a miracle to have in this
film yeah because it it's not just about
it it's this movie isn't what I would
expect it's not what anyone would expect
MH because it touches on the Muslim
faith it touches on the Buddhist and
Shinto faiths of Asia uh even Hinduism
and um and and I believe the Lord wants
to reach people in all of those places
too amen and their testimony is so
powerful it will it will convict and com
uh it's so compelling because Samuel
grew up in a Muslim family she grew up
in a Muslim family they uh were able to
escape Iraq during the war in the late
80s
and they were in Sweden she was so
unhappy she tried to take her life
several times slid her wrists you'll see
pictures in the film of of actual scars
on her wrists and Samuel um was in LA
and became a very successful real estate
agent and um and he was introduced to a
life coach who started introducing him
to New Age practices and that's how he
got involved in meditation but then his
mother died while he was rising to like
the number
14 greatest real estate agent as far as
uh Commissions in the
country and but when his mother died who
was his everything he wanted to know
about the afterlife yeah he wanted to
reach her and so he he had done magic
mushrooms he had he had believed very
sincerely that he had had past lives
which is very prevalent in the New Age
which comes from Hinduism where did get
it from it came from Shamanism before
them and so Samuel went to do iasa but
he also invited his niece to come also
because she was trying to take her life
and she was looking for hope so when
they remember we were talking earlier
about intention and surrender when they
came to the iasa by the way the shaman
is always a facilitator at these
ceremonies and um and so they would come
and they told their intention he wanted
to speak to his dead mother before the
ceremony begins and she asked for the
truth wow she was so desperate about her
life she didn't know her purpose for
living and this was the first time you
hear in the movie later the shaman was
calling him and asking about her because
he had been practicing for 25 years and
no one had ever asked for the truth
before wow 25 years wow and so that
becomes this amazing inspiration of this
film is how Jesus will reach down
wherever someone is he knows your heart
and here they are practicing um this
iasa and I'm going to show you a clip
that shows actual footage the day after
one of their iasa ceremonies and what he
saw that he thought was his dead mother
wow
wow so the other way those spirits they
won my trust my full trust is what it
looked like my dead mother and she talks
like her she acts like her and my mother
came down in a spaceship she knows my
soul so when I asked her about who I am
she said of course she's around me her
wings are everywhere she protects me
every day every day my mother was my
everything so if my mother is telling me
something of course I will do because I
know she only wants what's the best for
me I was is very
intelligent I was able to tap into that
my sister had
a I saw as beginning stage of breast
cancer in her left breast and I texted
her that and it was amazing that she's
been to the doctor like there was a
health thing possibly a big Health thing
it keeps reconfirming the message of
that I can see visions that it's real
and it's just like I love that I love
channeling
that well at least we know the demons
are consistent spaceship yeah yep right
and this just shows you how prevalent
this is this is uh from Oregon just last
month um there is a waiting list for one
of the first licensed siloy service
centers in
Oregon um says here that the weight list
of more than
3,000 uh includes people with depression
PTSD and end of life
dread and so here you have sort of the
Fountain Head and the Cry of humanity
searching for answers and what do they
experience geometric shapes loss of
identity and Oneness with the universe
is that kind of what Jim Carrey went
down that road is that what he was like
a there is no Jim Carrey and I'm just
one with everything is this kind of the
same sort of that's what shaman that's
where Shamanism and animism takes you is
that is that humanity and nature and
planets they everything is one and so
pantheism the word we use is is is is is
essentially the same thing so I see kind
of this two- facet thing not only are
they slamming who God is diminishing who
he is but then they're also like
diminishing you as an individual like
you are just you know you're just this
Speck of dust like every other Speck of
dust rather than you are this individual
that God came down and actually died for
that your price is
infinite in the universe you know is
there something to this always having to
ingest something to inch to achieve this
altered state going back to the Garden
of Eden they had to ingest something is
there anything to that the Matrix in our
modern world take the blue pill red pill
do you remember what was said when they
took that this disrupts the input output
signal so that we can pinpoint where you
are and we come find you if that's not
anog analogy for the Demonic world right
maybe that's what that does is cuts off
your communication and opens your
communication to the spirit world around
you yeah it is it it it has a very
consistent effect on the human brain it
shuts down uh the frontal lobe it and
this actually is validating the
prophecies in Revelation so clearly to
me now because the Bible in Revel
calls it a mark on the forehead right
and in the hand so first you have to put
something in your mouth and secondly how
does it affect your thought process this
is this is the frontal lobe is actually
what gives you the red flag and it sorts
about everything you knew from the past
everything you have there is filtering
constantly and that goes down when you
take this and it says that the dragon is
going to deceive the whole world through
sorcery magic mushrooms phia
Pharmaceuticals exactly he's going to
and it's all about the smart and yet
this is becoming more normalized more
mainstream people are more more people
have depression PTSD are feeling
suicidal so this is going to become like
everybody's on something either you're
on you know ADHD medicine or you're on
anti-depressant or you're on psilocybin
I mean everybody's going to be on
something it's interesting you say the
whole world I remember and maybe you can
remind me the person that said this in
the film there was I believe a priest
who was saying how all the other
religions are pretty much on the same
page in terms of Christ being in you and
achieving different stages and whatnot
except for one and was Pro protestantism
which is why we see such an attack on it
all these celebrities are coming out of
the Christian faith and going into all
of these Spirit spiritualism to group it
all together so do you think
that they will succeed in completely
roping in protestantism with everything
else well it's essentially already done
in a from from a um see God always has a
Remnant yeah throughout history there's
always a Remnant that hasn't bowed the
knee to bail First Kings 18 or 19 when
God is talking to Elijah Elijah says
take my life I'm just a guy I'm no
better than my father's you threw me out
there on Mount Carmel and we had a great
Victory but the truth is I'm just dust
you know take my life he was depressed
yeah and God said don't worry you're not
alone cuz he cuz Elijah told God I'm the
last one left and that's kind of how it
feels today sometimes doesn't it
sometimes we who are Protestants and by
the way thank you for bringing that up
because yes it was very subtle how the
Lord led me to include
fundamentalism and show how it relates
to Heretics from the Dark Ages who were
burned be for no other reason than they
were reading the Bible for themselves
right you could not have and I list
those in the film so people can research
this stuff if they want to on their own
I didn't want to just make statements
that people couldn't find out if they
wanted to if the holy spirit is tapping
someone on the shoulder dive in study
for yourself yeah but yes it was a death
decree if you owned any part of the
scriptures of on your own in the in your
local language yeah and so yes
protestantism is essentially dead today
you have people like Rick Warren um who
wrote the book um the purpose-driven
life which is a bestseller for many
years um he's a promoter of spiritual
formation the the christianized form of
of mysticism and the movement away from
a very very clear teaching of an
absolute truth because then you can join
hands with other religions Jesus becomes
marginalized Jesus becomes like the
ascended masters of the new age he's
just one among many along with the
Virgin Mary by the way yeah and there
are quotes in the film where we
eventually get to the Antichrist we
eventually show how in their very
catechism they're teaching shamanistic
practices of ancestor worship W
including praying to Mary praying to the
Saints and even praying to your own dead
relatives and with them wow even the
word fundamentalist now just has this
cringe like you hear it's just like like
a stigma to it but there's nothing wrong
with it's great it's we should be
fundamentalist just someone who reads
and believes the Bible yeah the lines
are being drawn um the the the labels
see it doesn't matter if you claim to be
Catholic or Protestant any more those
those label and how many 40,000
Christian denominations now those labels
are
meaningless do you follow Jesus all the
way or do you follow the devil and his
minions all the way I mean I think that
we are really witnessing what Jesus
talked about the wheat and the tears
growing up together like there's this
fully matured one side or the other
there's no middle ground I want to show
one more thing before we wrap up and
that is this um
Japanese segment of World War II that's
just real short that will give a little
glimpse into what we were talking about
earlier of the no self because
ultimately what they're preaching as
Enlightenment these Altered States this
is a term that sounds like sainthood
right like it's the highest Pinnacle
that you could arrive at in the west
that's what we've been taught but that's
what was shocking when I learned what
happened in World War II and the fact
that there's no morality there you can't
tell right from wrong and that's why
being a fundamentalist being a
Protestant fundamentalist by the way
that term arose in early 20th century
protestantism for anyone who's wondering
the fundamentalist sounds like an evil
term because it was labeled for the
jihadists that were blowing up buildings
just 20 years ago when they blew up 9 on
911 right they were called
fundamentalists and so suddenly it was
an evil an evil term but it arose in
protestantism isn't that something and
what did it mean it meant people Tru
people who believe in the Bible is the
God's absolute truth for
mankind isn't that
something so oh which which is a misuse
of the word then because those people
believe in the Quran not even the Bible
yeah right so why was that appli to
them in his groundbreaking book Zen at
War Zen priest and historian Brian
Victoria shows how during World War II
the Japanese military used Zen ideas and
meditation techniques with the support
of Zen Buddhist
[Music]
leaders soldiers learned how to attain
Enlightenment or the no so a nonu
reality where neither they nor the enemy
exist and no one gets killed
[Music]
so DT Suzuki was was the most famous Zen
Buddhist M Zen ma zen zen master
Buddhist Master uh in the 20th century
and he was the Fountain Head of what
became mindfulness
in the United States and is heavily
promoted now but what's really important
is that he was confronted after World
War II and he was asked and confronted
about how these Japanese kamakazi could
just dive without any fear and create
all of this this massive destruction on
on Humanity suicide just how do you get
them all to be suicidal yeah and and
then when when the West found out about
what Zen Buddhists were doing with their
soul soers in
Japan DT Suzuki was confronted because
he was already a celebrity here in the
United States at that time Wow and his
answer was this Enlightenment the no
self is not enough there is no morality
in the altered state mercy so so you
mean you think about what level you
could engage against what this is
fighting against is God has these 10
comprehensive laws to protect everyone
around so that you don't harm other
people you don't harm yourself like you
don't harm your relationship with God
right and this idea of like none of that
matters I mean that's just literally
listening to The Whispers of Satan
himself it's a spirit of lawlessness and
if you really thought like that why be
married why have why do anything moral
if there's no morality whatsoever and it
doesn't matter and you're not real and
they're not real and why wouldn't you do
whatever gratifies your selfishness no
well in fact you just nailed the very
Fountain Head the first reference to
nonduality written reference in history
is shown in this film and it was
shocking to me it was shocking to me
because it shows the first reference to
transgenderism in history it was in
Mesopotamia these Temple priests would
castrate themselves while they worshiped
the goddess inana which became Ishtar
which
became the Queen of Heaven and worshiped
as as the planet Venus which is all the
other famous goddesses of his history
came from her right Isis came from that
but the point is is these Temple priests
would castrate themselves in trance this
is key this this lawlessness this lack
of morality this place where the devil
takes a mind and disconnects them from
their
creator because in
nonduality were by the way there's a
quote it's it one of the Gods created
them neither NE Nei male nor female
there's a quote in there so nonduality
came from there in a Trans State where
the connection between Creator and
creature gender differences evil and
good they all disappear and then become
one so evil coexists with good eternally
in non-duality which that concept popped
up in the beginning chapter of the Bible
it's like the first thing that God
established there's a male there's a
female and then you look at what
Satanism promotes right baet is both and
or gen androgenic so he's like male and
female right so I mean you can just tell
real quick God is about the male and
female anything that's androgenic
where's that coming from by the way
there's a quote from Helena batki the
famous occultist who's the Forerunner of
the new age and she actually very openly
said all of the gods and goddesses and
the ancient Pantheon are
androgynous and she said our God our
Lucifer she actually says that our
Lucifer is the same thing as the morning
star in Venus he is the same thing as
Ishtar in other words all of these gods
and goddesses that humans are worshiping
are really worshiping Lucifer himself
wow that's what saying we would be
called radical fundamentalists for
believing that yet she's saying the same
thing the new aging right but now the
push is to have the god of Heaven and
the Creator to be in jous or like God is
a woman sort using she that's what
mysticism does to the Bible and there's
many quotes from so-called Christian
monks Christian Mystics admitting that
that mysticism gives you wisdom in the
scriptures to see it more clearly and so
this unlearning happens in the altered
state and then the devil can actually
rewire your the way you perceived Paul
and Jesus even Jesus going into the
desert they claim he's a Mystic because
he went into the desert like Paul did
and these these quotations where you
where
uh uh you are in Christ you are a new
creature all all of these statements
that have to do with transformation of
the human heart they have nothing to do
with Essence yeah the nature of man
doesn't change but the transformation of
the spirit does make you into to a new
person right that's what we're promised
but there's still a pull of the flesh
there's still that Humanity that's part
of us we are not gods and so they twist
these things in the scriptures and that
that is um that's why we need the Holy
Spirit yeah because this deception is
becoming so close so
beautiful I think it's beautiful that
you incorporated into this film a story
of somebody that asked God for truth
because I believe that you know like
like in Joshua's day when those people
put on raggedy clothes and they brought
like you know all this like moldy bread
and they said they came from some far
out country right they did God did not
let them know that was a deception
because they never asked but God is like
wanting to direct our paths in fact
that's what it says in the Bible right
he'll tell us to go to the left or to
the right right but you got to ask you
got to ask Jesus to come inside you got
to ask the Holy Spirit to make sense of
this if you're reading all this stuff a
simple remedy for this is just ask God
lord show me if this is right or this is
wrong amen ask God to reveal that truth
from you from his word not from some
Mystic book or from some exterior thing
right because you know that's man
creating those those documents that
Bible that is the source of truth and
the line of truth if you ask God show me
what the truth is here and show it to me
from your word he won't ignore you and
you'll always find Jesus cuz the the
devil can't provide that there's no
light there's no truth within him so the
only person to answer that question is
Jesus which is why he can reach out to
anyone at any state I want to uh I want
to Echo your words and and remember my
favorite probably my favorite Bible
verse and I keep it on a tapestry I was
a I was a uh English teacher back in the
day in Korea and so my my my English
students in Korea made this Korean
language tapestry of Jeremiah 29
913 and it's kind of like what we're
talking about today if you saw the
tapestry in my house and you didn't know
Korean it would just be Greek to you
right but everything you just said is
about Experiencing God and that verse
says you will seek me and find me if
when you search for me with how much all
your heart all of your heart beautiful
you have to be all in and Jes Jesus is
not playing hide-and seek from Humanity
in fact the whole message of this film
is that Jesus Christ is a person MH who
came and died for a rebel
planet and that you can know him and
they are claiming that you can't
experience him unless you go into mys
mysticism and practices like they
promote because he's inside you already
but in fact Jesus told us to pray Our
Father who is where in in heaven
directly to him Hallowed Be Your Name
he's he's in heaven that's where Jesus
the fir and and that's that's a
traditional prayer from the Bible and
they are totally skipping past that yeah
so the god of Heaven actually and
Jeremiah 1 ver5 is one of my favorite
verses also because he's the Lord says
to Jeremiah before I formed you in your
mother's womb I knew you mhm and I I uh
I made you I separated you to be a
prophet to the Nations but the point is
is that God knew you from eternity
because he created time and space he's
the only Transcendent one that's he's
the one who can come into our time
linear time realm and take over our
faculties or give us thoughts he should
stop and pick up that person like you
were sharing but it is all filtered
through his word M MH and that's what we
have as fundamentalist Christians is we
have a filter and we're promoting that
filter and mystify so then let me ask
you this as you said the film is 3 hours
long and as I sat down to watch it the I
was familiar with a lot of the things in
there but if I hadn't known anything at
all I would probably be pretty
overwhelmed by all the information as
there although I will say that you did a
great job in carrying a person from the
beginning to the end and going through
all the information what would you say
to someone who's asking how important is
it to know all of this all the
terminology all the deceptions why can't
I just block everything off and focus
directly on the word of
God I'm not I'm not saying that every
you know I I believe I don't believe
that God is in a box I believe this film
is going to be for the people that God
intends to watch it it's it's like
beware of angels and Charmed by Darkness
there was a there was an elderly woman
who saw beware of angels and she was she
was afraid she had nightmares after she
watched it um but there are so many
hundreds of people that I know who have
reached out who found Jesus through
those films and so it so this film I'm
not saying is for everyone to watch in
fact one of the key things for a
filmmaker is to constantly ask yourself
who's your audience right MH mhm and the
truth is this is probably the broadest
audience that I've ever imagine and the
reason is is because of what's going on
in our culture today there are so many
Christians who believe in the Bible as
the absolute truth who
are questioning what's going on because
we don't have a context historically
there isn't any place you can go to
understand how Shamanism is actually
underg guring all of what we're seeing
whether it's IND see it used to be
indigenous peoples in Africa and the
Eskimo tribes up in the north uh the
American Indians who've all practiced
different versions of shamanism but
Shamanism actually underg guards what
what Buddhism is and Hinduism is and
most people don't know that and so this
rise of psychodelic drugs the legalizing
of them the the promotion of mindfulness
meditation and where does it come from
and what does it do to the human brain
um there there are some practical
effects for people who believe in the
Bible and believe in Jesus Christ as
their savior that this could be a
resource to share with their friends and
family who maybe are dabbling in this
yeah and there are many who believe in
Jesus but perhaps haven't surrendered
and so there is a battle going on um
from the culture from the fallen angels
and even in our own soul because the
Bible says the heart is deceitful above
all things and desperately with Wicked
who can know it so the the whole journey
of this is something that I wouldn't
have signed up for for myself you know
studying the occult studying all of what
these where these Journeys take one if I
hadn't personally been in prayer and
memorizing God's word literally and I
encourage the viewers also start
memorizing whole passages so that the
Holy Spirit can teach you context of
what's being taught in these different
places of scripture not one verse here
and there um it it's a lifestyle choice
and I believe the Lord has used that to
Shield me from this this heavy material
but the beautiful thing is is that it
leads you to the truth about Jesus it
doesn't stay here it's like for the
Buddhist that's out there that doesn't
have any context for the Bible at all
and and quite frankly what used to be a
Protestant Nation before I was born is
Now quickly becoming a a very much A
Bess Godless mhm Nation there's a Bible
in every home but people don't read it
right and so we have this we have now
this Melting Pot of whatever you believe
is your truth and I know you guys talk a
lot about this and this was the first
like this is the this is the first
resource that I think I've seen
personally that actually tries to unpack
it in a way way that gives a historical
context all the way back to the Garden
of Eden cuz you know there's some
disconnects in history and a lot of
these leaders misrepresent history and
they say that Jesus and the apostles
were Mystics how do you answer that I I
I think you're hitting on the head of
why I would I
would probably encourage people even if
you have nothing to do with this you may
come across somebody and if our all our
sole purpose is to share share truth
with people right if you know a little
bit about this sometime down the road
you're equipped with no no no no I know
I I know where the truth of that is let
me let me let me share with you from the
Bible from the word of God what the real
truth of this is if you don't have a
context of that and somebody you know is
looking into that a coworker or a friend
or you know someone you're in a
relationship with you know it can be
helpful for you to know a little bit
about this kind of topic so and okay you
said is exactly what I say about the
alien topic too when I share that I'm
like there may be a lot of people in
this room that say yep I believe aliens
or demons but how are you going to
convince that to your neighbor who's not
a Christian who isn't reading the Bible
that's why you have to look at these
things like huh that's strange they
appear when you meditate right oh you
can Channel them they walk through walls
they split in two there's things that
there's there's U little proofs of
evidence that show you that these are
not just physical beings beings from
another world they're interdimensional
deceivers and so yeah like just like you
said like how are you going to what
evidence are you going to show somebody
who doesn't believe the same way you do
we have to have other sources and not
just to other people to yourself like
would we be able to understand the
prophecies in Daniel if we didn't know
the history of Babylon Meo Persia Greece
and all these things so it's the same
with prophecy that's forward looking
right so if you don't have an awareness
of what's happening around not that you
need to know everything which is and we
all have different capacities but having
an awareness of it will help validate
and help you understand the things that
are being talked about in the Bible but
it also will help equip people in this
Warfare let me give you one example that
I think might be helpful in your uh kind
of helping to illustrate your question
my brother is a pastor and has been for
decades and he is now a leader in the
7th Day Adventist Church and he shared
an experience with me he's been f
following this journey I've been on this
this research Journey for two plus years
and and he told me himself that he's
learned a lot about what's going on in
the christianized form of mysticism as a
result of this stuff that God's given me
to do one day he was on a conference
call I won't give names but he was on a
conference call with uh where there was
a large group of people that were all
discussing a a teenage Bible study
curriculum and my brother is a youth
pastor that's in
leadership um and there was a Catholic
priest a Jesuit Catholic priest uh on
the on the call who was one of who was
sitting next to a facilitator who was
part of a Evangelical Theological
Seminary not a denom it was a non-
denominational kind of pitch that could
bring all of Christianity together to to
promote uh one message to teens about
Jesus but because of what my brother had
learned through this journey God gave
him a discernment a certain sensitivity
to what was being said remember this
idea that we join hands with all the
faiths to come together that's what the
Jesuit movement is all about to destroy
the Protestant voice right and while
they were in this
conversation discussing the development
and they all had outlines that were
presented by this Theological Seminary
and the priest was part of that
leadership team that was
presenting and toward the end the uh
priest made this comment that suddenly
the red flag took off in my brother's
mind and none of his colleagues caught
caught it yeah and it wasn't until after
the call that my brother reached out to
these other leader decision makers they
were ready to sign up by the way I won't
say who they were MH but God used this
knowledge here's what the Catholic
priest said he says oh um if there's
anything that um that you don't like
don't worry we can we can take it we can
make it whatever it needs to
be and they're talking here about a
Biblical Based Teaching tool for teens
about the Bible but we can make it up as
you need it to be made up we can change
whatever you want wow and suddenly my
you know because when you're talking
with people of other Faith we're
supposed to build Bridges we're supposed
to have a community that says we love
Jesus too there's a lot of people out
there who don't think sth Day Adventists
love Jesus that we're all about the
law no we love Jesus that's why we are
what we are that's right we have a
calling to present the truth as it is in
him so my brother was sensitized does
that make sense it does that's a good
answer for sure and the Holy Spirit
promises to bring back to memory the
things that you have studied right well
to bring back you has to be in there to
begin with so it's important to study
these things out amen I've been super
blessed by this conversation and I'm
telling you guys if you want to check
out this film October 29 what time is it
going to be
played subscribe on our YouTube channel
yes there will be a link on this
interview page I'm sure true stream
media live streams media that's right
and um we're going to post the time as
soon as we put out the premiere link we
don't we haven't selected it cuz we have
we have people around the world that
we're trying to make it as convenient
for them as possible well I'll tell you
what go to Liv stream media right now
subscribe to it so you'll get that
notification and if you haven't seen his
previous two films I would suggest go
and watch those films can they watch it
on your YouTube channel as well yep go
and watch those two films so you have a
real good basis because this is going to
explain a lot more detail and I'm
excited that you got this done and I'm
I'm I'm looking forward to seeing how
God blesses you in this film thank you
thank you so much Scotty Mikey and Candy
y like And subscribe to our content as
well if you like these kind of
conversations we want to hear from you
what did you think about some of those
topics that were brought up and uh feel
free to leave a comment if you want uh
of course you know if you'd feel like
you'd like to support this ministry to
go forward you can check out little
light studios. TV there's little donate
button at the top or you can become a
patreon and uh we sell t-shirts you can
go to uh lightwe lightwear do shop and
that's where you can get some awesome
t-shirts to promote you know some
wholesome things out into the world and
always as always we covered your guys'
prayers we thank you for watching we'll
see you next week bye it's proven that
people remember things that they see
more than what they hear lightwear
believes the best way to share your
witness is to wear your witness
lightwear has all kinds of graphic te's
that are a great attention grabbing way
to share the gospel so head on over over
to lightwear do shop and check out all
the cool graphic te's what do you want
people to remember when they see
you if you're looking for good wholesome
educational content for your children
subscribe to our new channel little like
[Music]
kids